I think that entrepreneurs,
when they go out to fundraise,
they have to think about it like,
I think, getting married.
You are about to bring somebody
on board to your business
that you can't undo afterwards.
So once you bring on board investors,
it's not only just your business.
And you have to acknowledge that and you
have to believe that that's the right
thing for you and
that's the right thing for the business.
If you can bootstrap, great.
If you don't have to fundraise, great.
But for the vast majority of
businesses in today's tech world,
you have to go out and raise money.
So the downside perhaps is that
it's no longer your business.
I actually think it can
be a very good thing,
because now you're accountable
not just to yourself but for
other people as well and people that
put their trust and money in you.
And that I find to be a very
invigorating thing for
a lot of entrepreneurs,
who already are working super hard,
actually upping their game,
because they appreciate
the responsibility that
comes with raising capital.